so we've known for a long time that even
people who eat very strictly vegan or
vegetarian without taking protein shakes
or whatever are getting about 70 to 80
grams of protein per day average some
more some less and then there's this
idea that the protein that we get from
meat is higher quality of protein I mean
the epidemiological evidence and the
health outcome evidence tells the
opposite Story the concept that we don't
get all the amino acids that we need to
get from our plant-based diet is also a
fallacy I mean all plants contain all of
the amino acids that humans need to be
healthy including the essential amino
acids in different proportion and if
you're eating a very rich diet that
includes fruits and vegetables and three
servings of whole grains and legumes you
will get all of those amino acids so if
you're going to use the whole protein
analogy a whole food plant-based diet is
a whole source of protein